zone Europe sur sensation
[Musique]
bienvenue dans un Europe sur Radio
sensation et sur TV 78 pour un numéro
spécial enregistré à Bad marine Berg en
Allemagne une petite ville rurale située
à l'ouest de l'Allemagne à mi-chemin
entre Francfort et Cologne et c'est ici
qu'a lieu donc la cinquième étape du
projet JIRA le projet pour les
initiatives vertes en zone rurale
zone Europe sur sensation
Marie rafale Mignet bonjour bonjour vous
êtes manager du Centre Europe Direct à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye et la chef de la
délégation française pour ce projet
Gérard alors ça y est c'est déjà la
cinquième étape du projet sur donc les
initiatives vertes en zone rurale alors
déjà elle m'a rien fait ce que vous
pouvez nous rappeler les grands
objectifs de ce projet Gira absolument
une volonté de six pays de travailler
ensemble dans le cadre d'un partenariat
stratégique erasmuse plus
afin de voir dans le cadre du Pacte vert
européen
comment faire pour rendre les zones
rurales plus agréables que les gens
cessent dans Partir quels sont les
initiatives qui peuvent être financées
qu'est-ce qui entre guillemets en
prenant en compte le changement
climatique le réchauffement etc permet
de mettre en oeuvre des initiatives dans
de petites zones isolées quelles sont
les participants de ce projet les
acteurs qui font vivre le projet alors
ce sont déjà les
six pays la Suède la Pologne et la Grèce
pour la plupart des organisations de la
société civile ou des maisons de
l'Europe et tous les gens qui nous
reçoivent sur place lors des meetings
alors des agriculteurs des fermiers des
commerçants des maires
qui viennent nous expliquer
en quoi il est important que leur zone
continue à vivre bien que éloignées et
isolés quelles peuvent être l'intérêt
d'échanger entre Européens sur ces
questions environnementales justement et
bien d'apprendre des autres des bonnes
pratiques de piocher des idées de se
dire que telle initiative qui a
fonctionné dans un village allemand pour
être pertinente en banlieue d'une ville
plus importante en France et
surtout de continuer à mettre
en place des idées ensemble vu que c'est
un projet européen et qu'on est censé
travailler aussi à l'échelle du
continent et l'Union et sur quoi ce
projet va-t-il déboucher alors sur des
bonnes pratiques sur un guide numérique
de bonne pratique
qu'on espère pouvoir rendre vraiment
visible pour que chacun puisse aller
piocher regarder donner son avis et
surtout aussi faire remonter peut-être à
la à la Commission européenne quels sont
les initiatives locales et quelles
difficultés rencontrent les acteurs
locaux notamment pour trouver des
financements européens et donc Marie
Raphaël pour finir nous sommes à Bad
marine Berg en rénalie Palatina c'est
une ville que vous connaissez bien oui
tout à fait d'abord parce que c'est la
plus ancienne Maison de l'Europe
d'Allemagne qui a été construite en 1951
et qui héberge des séminaires de jeunes
où j'ai eu la chance de pouvoir
intervenir plusieurs fois en
accompagnant des groupes scolaires merci
Marie Raphaël merci beaucoup
zone Europe sur sensation
la reine Annie Palatina est le Land le
plus forestier d'Allemagne la région est
composée à 42% de forêts et donc un
enjeu majeur ici on écoute Anica
baumeers elle est éducatrice
environnementale à Batman Berg
qui est une très petite ville de la
région de Oued Serval dans l'ouest de
l'Allemagne
tout est recouvert de forêt c'est pour
cela que nous l'appelons la forêt de
l'Ouest
c'est très culturel émotionnel les gens
ici disent que nous avons besoin de
cette forêt de façon écologique comme de
façon économique mais aussi c'est très
social les gens aiment y passer leur
temps libre cette région est couverte de
petites villes et villages les
ressources principales sont le bois et
les richesses présentes dans le sol
alors ce sont les forêts et les sols qui
sont ici les principales sources de
revenus en raison du changement
climatique nous nous sommes rendus
compte que nous devions absolument
protéger ses forêt êts nous avons besoin
des surfaces au sol mais aussi de la
forêt en tant que tel nous devons nous
protéger des conséquences du changement
climatique
le réchauffement s'est accéléré et les
températures ont augmenté rapidement
causant de nombreux dommages alors avec
moins de pluie les arbres se dessèchent
les pains les conifères sont les plus
affectés mais pas seulement les chaînes
aussi
des maladies apparaissent c'est de
nombreuses aires ont été déforestés nous
voyons les dommages tout autour de nous
les arbres sont très secs
ont commencé à s'investir à créer des
initiatives en se disant ok on a besoin
de replanter les arbres nous ne pouvons
pas attendre jusqu'à ce qu'il repousse
naturellement car cela prend trop de
temps plus de 60 ans pour que la forêt
soit comme avant les organisations de
protection de l'environnement et c'est
de créer un habitat sur pour les plantes
et pour les espèces animales ainsi nous
essayons de rétablir l'équilibre de
l'écosystème
est très importante pour les enfants les
adolescents mais également toutes les
personnes désireuses que le système
fonctionne il y a de nombreux programmes
sur la zone gérée par des gens qui
veulent en prendre soin
et cette forêt il faut aussi en prendre
soin on en parle d'ailleurs avec Michael
Kyle il est membre d'une association
environnementale à Batman Berg
nature
et du groupe local de Bad marine Berg
nous sommes à peu près 3600 membres ici
et je fais partie du conseil
d'administration
notre association a pour but de protéger
notre environnement immédiat nous
protégeons les habitats nous essayons de
protéger certaines espèces de plantes et
d'animaux
nous nous trouvons ici dans une petite
vallée avec des espèces d'oiseaux
spécifiques une compagnie a souhaité
venir extraire des pierres et c'est
compliqué de les en empêcher
nous avons vraiment des espèces
d'oiseaux très particulières comme un
certain type de hibou
il y a ici des températures plus basses
que dans le reste de la vallée alors
nous essayons de réhabiliter l'habitat
de certains types d'espèces bien
précises
nous sommes maintenant à quelques
kilomètres de Batman Berg dans la
réserve naturelle
ici une forêt commémorative a été mise
en place l'objectif dans les prochaines
années sera d'y planté un total de 100
000 arbres on écoute bien le flic alors
aujourd'hui
village de la région mais c'est une
initiative très importante car c'est une
des premières sur les 20 parcelles
replantées ici juste ici il y a environ
1000 arbres mais sur l'ensemble de la
zone on compte 45 milliards vont
replanter une planifions d'en planter
100 000 de plus au cours des trois
prochaines années il est important de
reconstruire la forêt à cause des
insectes qui tu les arbres dans la forêt
ce projet n'est plus qu'il était
auparavant un modèle pour l'ensemble de
la région en ce qui concerne la forêt
commémorative nous avons eu cette idée
car il n'y a rien de ce genre dans la
région le concept quand quelqu'un meurt
une nouvelle vie ça apparaître ici au
plantain d'arbres ici nous n'avons
aucune restriction tout le monde peut
acheter et planter un arbre on peut le
faire par exemple pour honorer la
mémoire d'un parent d'un grand parent
disparu c'est très commun comme coutume
ici en Allemagne on retrouve une
atmosphère de recueillement totalement
différente que devant une tombe d'un
être cher on se recueille dans une forêt
protéger la nature et la biodiversité ce
sont les objectifs de l'association et
burtzen une association fondée en 2007
par des biologistes des défenseurs de
l'environnement on écoute Peter marzazen
dès ce pack forme
intempestive c'est un parc un zoo mais
qui appartient à une ONG alors il n'est
pas commercial il existe depuis environ
65 67 ans et la plupart d'entre nous qui
travaillons dans une association de
protection de la nature avons connu ce
parc depuis que nous sommes enfants
nous ne pouvions pas supporter l'idée
qu'il ferme alors nous avons pensé à des
façons de combiner la protection de la
nature avec une mise en avant des
animaux de la région et en effet ça
marche
of good project le but de notre
association est le suivant crée des
zones bien protégées de petits biotopes
dont les espèces même celles qui
n'existent plus dans notre région pour
en profiter
c'est comme toute chose dans la vie il
suffit juste de se lancer si nous étions
allés à la ferme vous auriez vu un grand
nombre de terrarium ce qui permettent la
reproduction d'espèces qui ont disparu
dans notre région en faisant cela nous
avons rendu à la région une dizaine
d'espèces alors on peut dire que ça
fonctionne
je vous disais que nous avions créé des
biotopes dans notre région ici nous nous
trouvons au coeur de notre activité nous
avons à peu près 40 hectares très proche
de cet étang alors les animaux peuvent
bouger de points
cette zone précise a été créée en 2018
il y a ici de nombreux oiseaux à cause
du point d'eau mais aussi de nombreuses
espèces de grenouilles d'amphibiens et
de salamandres
direction la ferme à présent nous sommes
à Neunkirchen Sven azenauer il possède
250 vaches la particularité de cette
exploitation tout est 100% bio
[Musique]
nous travaillons un système à la fois
naturel et circulaire tout est basé sur
des produits naturels des animaux que
nous élevons nous-mêmes nous utilisons
également le fumier produit par les
vaches comme engrais nous n'utilisons
pas de nourriture additionnelle les
animaux ont tout ce dont ils ont besoin
ici
les bêtes que nous élevons ici sont des
charolaises de France
nous avons observé pendant longtemps
comment les vaches s'adaptent à leur
environnement ici c'est maintenant
évident qu'elle s'adapte très bien un
petit investissement rapporte ici de
grandes quantités de viande
les gens avec qui nous avions travaillé
au cours des 12 dernières années ont
réalisé récemment que nos anciennes
façons de travailler de traiter la
nature n'était pas les bonnes
ils se sont rendus compte que c'est
notre manière de faire qui est la
meilleure en travaillant en harmonie
avec les ressources que nous avons à
notre disposition ici cela représente un
grand pas pour cette région
nous avons testé de nombreux biais pour
vendre notre viande et la meilleure
façon de faire et d'avoir des contacts
directs par exemple nous travaillons
directement avec une chaîne nationale de
supermarché mais aussi directement avec
les consommateurs qui viennent ici pour
visiter la ferme et acheter la viande
directement ici tous salut la qualité de
la viande que nous produisons ici
ce qui est très important pour nous
le développement durable c'est aussi une
affaire de jeunes dans ce lycée
professionnel situé à Westerburg les
enseignants ont décidé d'organiser une
journée spéciale dédiée au développement
durable celle-ci aura lieu fin mars on
écoute tout de suite Christine trepaire
l'une des enseignantes
le développement durable est très
important important dans notre école
dans l'enseignement nous avons pensé que
notre méthode d'enseignement elle-même
doit être durable afin que les élèves en
garde les acquis toute leur vie notre
institution est devenue beaucoup plus
durable mais nous avons encore un long
chemin parcourir nous avons décidé de
susciter une prise de conscience sur ce
sujet afin que les enseignants et les
élèves et l'opportunité de montrer que
dans toute notre région nous pouvons
travailler sur le développement durable
nous sommes une école très importante
avec des branches différentes le
développement durable devrait être une
base de référence pour tous les secteurs
d'enseignement c'est ce que nous
souhaitons montrer lors de la journée
portes ouvertes
nous voulons montrer aux gens des
activités très différentes avec de la
nourriture responsable et des façons
cuisinées plus durable une pièce de
théâtre une sorte de scénario dystopique
un peu triste dans lequel l'humanité est
condamnée car elle n'a pas été assez
responsable
nous avons coopéré avec les élèves
charpentiers qui ont construit la scène
et le décor avec du bois recyclé
nous avons également une salle appelée
jardin d'enfants dans laquelle les
enseignants et les élèves apprennent à
mettre en œuvre des projets autour du
développement durable chaque groupe
d'élèves et c'est de montrer quelque
chose qu'il a réalisé avec cette optique
de durabilité
quand j'essaie de susciter une prise de
conscience sur le développement durable
ou le climat certains étudiants
connaissent beaucoup de choses sur le
sujet mais certains rien du tout et il
ne pense pas quand ils vont faire des
courses qui pourraient acheter les
produits durables
c'est totalement nouveau pour eux ils
sont choqués si vous leur montrez ce qui
est en train de se passer à cause du
changement climatique parfois aussi cela
les rend triste et déprimé
zone Europe sur sensation
bonjour Olivier
municipal de Saint-Germain-en-Laye vous
faites partie de la délégation française
du projet Gira pour ce meeting en
Allemagne alors plusieurs sujets ont été
abordés au cours de smiting d'abord la
forêt quand on pense à l'Allemagne on
pense beaucoup parfois à des villes de
grande densité mais pourtant il est
aussi des Landes très forestiers comme
le rire Nanny Palatina où nous nous
situons comment est-ce qu'on gère la
forêt ici en Allemagne est-ce que c'est
différent qu'en France alors oui c'est
différent en France parce qu'évidemment
en France on a l'ONF le fameux Office
National des Forêts qui intervient
effectivement dans la gestion de ce
qu'on appelle la filière bois ici ils
ont une gestion un peu différente de la
forêt en ce sens que alors les forêts
évidemment comme chez nous d'ailleurs
elles sont
pour partie publique pour partie privée
parfois ici et en Allemagne sans doute
beaucoup plus que nous gérée par des
associations mais ils ont pas
d'organismes national qui chapeautent en
fait c'est géré à l'échelon plutôt
régional ou même extra local avec des
choix de gestion différents pas toujours
très cohérent en fonction des différents
acteurs c'est il y a pas d'harmonisation
comme il peut y avoir chez nous sur la
filière bois faut dire que le territoire
allemand est un peu plus vaste que le
territoire français mais comme tu le
disais exactement les gens sont
davantage concentrés dans des grandes
villes et finalement dans la zone dans
laquelle on est il y a assez peu
d'urbanisation beaucoup de forêts et ils
font parfois le choix par exemple de
laisser des arbres morts mourir et
recharger le sol en humus ce qui se fait
très peu ou quasiment pas chez nous où
on a peut-être moins de forêt
sauf dans les Landes mais dont
l'exploitation est plus évident que
qu'ici parfois il y a des choix
d'associations qui sont de laisser
simplement les arbres mourir et enrichir
le sol vous parlez donc des associations
environnementales ici en Allemagne tout
à fait on a pu en découvrir deux au
cours de ce midi il y a un dynamisme
local associatif très important on a pu
le voir est-ce que la situation qui
s'appelle qui s'occupe des oiseaux qui
s'appelle mupe je me rappelle si je me
souviens bien qui regroupe 900 000
habitants 900 000 adhérents pardon donc
effectivement oui il y a des
associations plus forts qu'en France
très présent bah je pense pas que la
ligue de protection des oiseaux en
France et 900 millions 900 000 pardon
presque un million d'habitants mais oui
effectivement les associations sont
assez assez présentes et importantes je
sais pas si elle pèse réellement ça j'en
ai absolument aucune idée mais elles
existent l'agriculture aussi était au
programme avec la visite de cette ferme
biologique à 100% avec 250 vaches alors
pourtant quand on pense aux
exploitations biologiques on pense
plutôt à des exploitations à taille
réduite là c'était quand même une
exploitation à plus grande échelle oui
je sais pas s'il y avait 250 vaches moi
oui d'accord j'ai pas bien j'ai pas bien
écouté
et effectivement oui c'est alors c'est
assez étonnant parce que d'abord ce qui
frappe quand on arrive sur le site c'est
que la ferme en elle-même est construite
en grande partie en bois alors que chez
nous les fermes les grandes fermes avec
les grands élevages ce sont quand même
des hangars la plupart du temps
métalliques là c'est en bois
les races qui sont cultivées hier on a
du bœuf Charolais quand même ici qui est
quand même un boeuf de de grande qualité
et ce qui est très étonnant alors oui
c'est bio c'est grand c'est construire
de manière assez charmante d'ailleurs
est-ce que nous expliquer en fait le le
propriétaire l'agriculteur c'est
auparavant quand son père avait monté le
projet au départ avec 50 vaches il avait
fait le choix de faire plutôt de
l'élevage et de la viande plutôt que du
lait parce que on lui disait que au
départ avec 50 vaches pour faire du lait
c'était insuffisant etc il en fallait
beaucoup plus bon effectivement les
activités d'élevage a permis de
d'accroître cet élevage et ce qui est
assez étonnant et le propriétaire nous
l'exploitant nous l'a expliqué c'est
qu'en fait auparavant il payait
énormément d'intermédiaires pour la
filière
alors bio ou pas bio d'ailleurs au
niveau de l'élevage et ils ont supprimé
ces intermédiaires et en fait ils
vendent directement à des grandes
surfaces dont je ne vais pas citer les
marques mais qui grandes surfaces
allemandes
dont notamment deux d'entre elles sont
présentes en France trois même je crois
évidemment ça a permis de réduire les
intermédiaires et donc les marges de
l'exploitation sont plus importantes ce
qui permet d'avoir des coûts
plus intéressant à la fois pour
l'éleveur mais aussi pour le
consommateur on reproche souvent à
l'alimentation bio d'être beaucoup plus
cher là forcément si on vend à des
grandes
discord on appelle ça forcément on
arrive à des prix beaucoup plus bas et
puis enfin les lycéens qui s'impliquent
sur les questions environnementales avec
des journées dédiées organisés dans
leurs établissements aujourd'hui éduquer
les jeunes aux enjeux environnementaux
c'est primordial c'est les enjeux de
demain oui quoi que je pense qu'ils sont
très préoccupés déjà moi je le vois rien
avec ma fille qui était anxieuse par
rapport à l'avenir de la plage je pense
que les jeunes sont sensibilisés mais
effectivement il y en a qui peuvent être
influencés par des parents
climatoceptiques
qui vont peut-être avoir besoin
effectivement d'une approche éducative
importante on a vu ici qu'en fait ils
avaient des systèmes de projection qui
ressemblent un peu à ce qu'on fait nous
en France et d'ailleurs y compris qu'on
voudrait faire dans les écoles de
Saint-Germain qui est la fresque du
climat c'est à dire une initiation
ludique à ce qui pourrait arriver si on
atteignait si on dépassait les 1 degrés
et demi ou les deux degrés ou les trois
degrés ou les 4 degrés ce qui conduirait
évidemment à des à des catastrophes on
l'a vu ici avec des slides de la même
manière que la fresque du climat est
présentée par exemple à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye et pour finir
Olivier s'il y a une chose à retenir de
ce déplacement à bas de marine Berg en
Allemagne ce serait quoi
ce serait ben moi ce qui me fera plus
quand même c'est cette fameuse gestion
de forêt qui me semble tout à fait
particulière et c'est vrai qu'on a on a
visité des endroits où on voit les
arbres qui sont laissés à l'abandon ils
vont mourir naturellement de leurs
belles morts ils sont plein de mousse et
ils vont enrichir le le sol on verra pas
ça en France on faudrait qu'on s'en
inspire selon vous bah je suis pas sûr
qu'en France on puisse le faire étant
donné d'abord que notre gestion de forêt
est différente que des forêts certes on
en a et des très grandes mais la forêt
des Landes la forêt des Vosges etc
les modes d'exploitation sont différents
dans les dans la forêt des Vosges par
exemple la filière bois est extrêmement
présente et on peut d'ailleurs se
demander si vaut pas mieux pour le
question de bilan carbone exploiter du
bois chez nous
plutôt que d'apporter du bois de Suède
ou d'Allemagne merci Olivier bassine de
rien
conseiller municipal en charge des
questions de développement durable à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye et membre de la
délégation française du projet Gira
merci à vous
sur sensation
zone Europe c'est terminé vous pouvez
retrouver cette émission en replay sur
notre site internet sur notre
application et sur notre chaîne YouTube
radio sensation et aussi sur TV 78 nous
on se retrouve la semaine prochaine pour
un nouveau numéro
[Musique]